podcasts Are Taking Over YouTube
everyone from financial influencers and
Gamers to fitness models and vloggers
all suddenly have a podcast
this is in stark contrast to everything
the media has been telling us our
attention span is shrinking long-form
content is dying conversely what seems
to be doing really well is actually
podcasts despite them breaking basically
every creative rule you can think of for
starters there are one to two hours long
if not longer also there's no fancy
editing sound effects music Graphics
coherent storytelling or any of that yet
despite all these quote-unquote
shortfalls podcasts are performing
better than ever the iced coffee hour
has nearly half a million Subs the pbd
podcast has 700 000 Subs Lex Friedman
has nearly 3 million subs and heck even
Logan Paul's podcast as four and a half
million Subs